You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛要承受很多压力。每天阅读、身处昏暗光线中、看屏幕时间太长，这些情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼睛疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛承受了很大的负荷。因此，通过定期视力检查来爱护它们并关注它们的健康状况非常重要。前往 Specsavers 进行 99 元起的眼科健康检查，其中包含 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段检测出眼部健康状况。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.cavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office
要查找附近的门店并预约 99 元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 specsavers.ca。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能因门店而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都将深入探讨《办公室》的世界
with exclusive interviews behind the seat. details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello, I want to wish you guys all the best day ever. You're very chipper. I am. Nice. I love it.
并带来独家采访、幕后细节以及许多闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女士 6.0”。大家好，祝你们今天过得最开心。你们今天很有精神。我是。很好。我喜欢。
I had some of those yogurt-covered gummy bears. Wait, what? You haven't had a yogurt-covered gummy bear? It sounds medicinal. These are regular gummy bears covered in yogurt? How much T-HC isn't there? There's none. There's none.
我吃了一些裹着酸奶的软糖熊。等等，什么？你没吃过裹着酸奶的软糖熊？听起来像药。这是裹着酸奶的普通软糖熊吗？里面有多少 THC（四氢大麻酚）？完全没有。一点也没有。
I'm like, is this explaining things? I got them in it. Like, at Christmas, from who? From Odyssey? To be fair. Odyssey, you got them as well. Your energy does seem subdued. Wait, you got them as well.
我在想，这算是在解释吗？我是收到的。就像，在圣诞节时，从谁那收到的？从奥德赛？说实话。奥德赛，你也收到了。你的精气神看起来确实有点低落。等等，你也收到了。
They were in our Christmas basket that they sent. That was so nice. And I was digging through that random snacks drawer in the pantry. Yeah. Josh was like, we got to clean out this snack's drawer. He decided to do it five minutes before I was walking out the door. But I was like, I'll take these yogurt coffee companies. And I ate him in the car.
它们在我们寄出的圣诞篮子里。那真是太好了。我在储藏室里乱七八糟的零食抽屉里翻找。是的。乔希说，我们得清理一下这个零食抽屉。他决定在我出门前五分钟动手。但我说，我要拿这些酸奶咖啡公司（注：此处疑为口误，指酸奶软糖熊）。我在车里把它们吃了。
I don't know what to tell you. They're really good. I mean, they're a couple months old, but they held up. Okay. I'll look for them. Highly recommend. How are you today? Well, lady, I've been better.
我不知道该对你说什么。它们真的很好吃。我是说，它们放了几个月了，但口感还不错。好吧。我会去找找看的。强烈推荐。你今天过得怎么样？嗯，女士，我今天状态不太好。
Oh. And I'll tell you why. Oh. I am so full of eggs. Eggs? I don't think I've ever consumed so many eggs. Why? And I'm sad about it.
哦。我来告诉你原因。哦。我吃了满满一肚子的鸡蛋。鸡蛋？我想我从来没有吃过这么多鸡蛋。为什么？而且我为此感到难过。
It's not going great for me. I'm so confused by this. Did you just make yourself a huge old omelet this morning? So I'm trying to eat more protein to build my lean mass with my weightlifting. And so I asked chat GPT to suggest some high protein meals. What did it say? It said that a great breakfast is to. two eggs plus three quarters of a cup of egg whites.
我最近过得不太顺。我对这事感到很困惑。你今天早上自己做了一个超大的煎蛋卷吗？为了配合举重训练增加瘦体重，我一直在努力多吃蛋白质。所以我让 ChatGPT 推荐了一些高蛋白餐点。它说了什么？它说一顿绝佳的早餐是：两个鸡蛋加上四分之三杯的蛋清。
Ew. Scramble. And a piece of toast with some avocado. What are you going to go? Chop down a tree? Lady, can I show you a picture of how many eggs I ate this morning? I made them and I was like, this would serve a family. That's a large plate.
呃。炒着吃。再加上一片涂了牛油果的吐司。你这是要去干嘛？去砍树吗？女士，我能给你看一张照片，看看我今天早上吃了多少鸡蛋吗？我做好后心想，这够一家人吃了。那是一个大盘子。
Yeah. And I ate them. You ate all of them. Did it. Do you feel a little gross? You do. I never want to eat another egg for the rest of my life. I went to chat GPT and I wrote, I said, hey, that was too many eggs for me. Could I get a different breakfast that's just as high in protein but less volume? And so it gave me some other suggestions. I'll try maybe tomorrow. But I still, I'm not over it. It was three hours ago. Yeah, your egg heavy. I am. Yeah. I should have had the gummy bear things. You're talking about I'd be in a better mood. Except I'm probably going to like sugar crash in like 15 minutes.
是的。而且我都吃光了。你把它们全吃完了。吃了。你觉得有点恶心吗？确实有点。我这辈子再也不想吃鸡蛋了。我去找 ChatGPT，然后写道：“嘿，对我来说鸡蛋吃太多了。能给我换个同样高蛋白但分量少一点的早餐吗？”于是它给了我一些其他的建议。也许我明天会试试。但我还是无法释怀。那是三个小时前的事了。是的，你今天摄入的鸡蛋太多了。确实。我当初应该吃那个软糖熊的。你说的那些，我心情可能会好一些。不过我大概会在 15 分钟内血糖骤降吧。
Well, my body better be making muscle right now. That's all I have to say. All right, body. Get on it. Listen, let's get to our fan chit chat question of the week. This one is coming in from Jonathan S in Tampa, Florida. Jonathan wanted us to read his suggestion. And here's what it is.
好吧，我的身体最好现在正在长肌肉。我只想说这些。好了，身体，加把劲。听着，我们来看看本周的粉丝闲聊问题。这个问题来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的乔纳森·S。乔纳森想让我们宣读他的建议。内容如下。
Jonathan says, who is responsible for raising and lowering the toilet seat? when at least one person in the household stands up to urinate. Oh, well, Jonathan, this sounds like you're ready to pick a fight. This might get spicy. Well, I have the answer to this question, and no one will ever have to wonder again. Okay. But I'd like you guys to weigh in as well. Okay.
乔纳森说：当家里至少有一个人站着小便时，谁负责把马圈放上去和放下来？哦，好吧，乔纳森，听起来你这是准备挑起争端啊。这可能会变得很有火药味。好吧，我有这个问题的答案，而且以后再也没有人需要为此纠结了。好吧。不过我也想听听你们的意见。好的。
Well, we've got two gals and two dudes here today. Yeah. Matt, Sam. Can I say something? Yes, Matt. To me, this one's a no-brainer. Everyone's responsible for lowering. The seed should be lowered at all times.
今天这里有两个姑娘两个小伙。是的，马特，萨姆。我能说句话吗？可以，马特。对我来说，这根本不用动脑筋。每个人都有责任把它放下。马桶圈应该随时保持放下状态。
This was one of the three main things I think my mom taught me from my childhood. It was don't smoke cigarettes, don't drink and drive, and lower the toilet seat every time. So your mom's point is if you raise it, then lower it. Correct. No-brainer. Yep, same with my mom. And don't use your teeth to open things. Packages.
这是我小时候我妈妈教给我的三件最主要的事情之一。那就是：不要抽烟，不要酒后驾车，每次用完都要把马桶圈放下。所以你妈妈的意思是，如果你把它抬起来了，就要放下去。没错。不用动脑筋。对，我妈也是这么说的。还有，不要用牙齿去开东西。包装袋。
You only get one set of teeth. My gosh, I love how this is segueed into advice from our moms. This is terrific. Yeah, my mom was like, the bathroom etiquette, you lower the seat. If you raised it, you lower it. She also said, Angela, men live their lives by the pecker between their legs. Remember that. So you, okay.
你只有一副牙齿。天哪，我喜欢这个话题是如何演变成我们妈妈的建议的。这太棒了。对，我妈当时说，关于卫生间礼仪，你得把马桶圈放下。如果你抬起来了，就得放下去。她还说，安吉拉，男人的一生都是被他们两腿之间的那个东西支配的。记住这一点。所以你，好吧。
She told me that when I was 16. I was like, oh, is this your version of a sex talk? I was going to say, and you picked up zero sexual phrases since then. That's the last one. Someone said to you that made sense. that my mom said to me, and I wasn't quite sure what a pecker was, but I figured it out. Great. Here's my thing.
我 16 岁的时候她对我说过这个。当时我想，哦，这就是你对我的性教育吗？我本来想说，从那以后你再也没吸收过半句跟性有关的话。那是最后一句。有人对你说过并且能听懂的话。我妈妈对我说过的话，当时我不太确定那是个什么东西，但我后来明白了。太棒了。我的看法是这样的。
It's math. I can bring it down to math. Oh, you like math. Yeah. And you know what? I love this. If you raise it, then you lower it, I think is a great way to think about it. But here's another way to think about it.
这是数学问题。我可以把它归结为数学。哦，你喜欢数学。对。你知道吗？我喜欢这样想：如果你抬起来了，就把它放下去，我觉得这是一种很好的思考方式。但还有另一种思考方式。
For the most part, women, pee sitting down and poo sitting down. Both of the things they're doing on the toilet require the seat to be down. Yes. men in general, pee standing up and they poo's sitting down. Some pee sitting down though. Some do. Fine.
大多数情况下，女性无论是小便还是大便都是坐着的。她们在马桶上做的这两件事都需要把马桶圈放下。是的。而男性通常站着小便，但大便时是坐着的。不过也有一些人站着小便。有些人是。好吧。
Well, that makes my argument even stronger. But what I'm saying is that two of the two things that women do on the toilet are seated, one of the two things. So there's four things happening on a toilet. So three out of the four times, someone goes to a toilet, the seat needs to be down. So this is math. I'm curious, Sam, Matt, have you guys ever peed sitting down? Yeah, absolutely.
那我的论点就更有说服力了。但我想说的是，女性在马桶上做的两件事中有两件是坐着的，（男性则是两件中的一件）。所以马桶上一共发生了四种情况。因此，在四分之三的情况下，当有人去上厕所时，马桶圈都需要是放下状态。所以这是数学问题。我很好奇，萨姆，马特，你们俩有坐着小便过吗？对，当然有。
That's music festivals all the time at Port-a-Potties. Oh, interesting. Why then? Why, why is that when you're sitting? That's when I'm standing to pee. I'm usually rolling on drugs. I'm usually rolling at the point. So I'm usually on mushrooms or something where I need to be sitting down.
音乐节的流动厕所里经常这样。哦，有意思。那为什么呢？为什么，为什么那种时候你会坐着？那是我通常站着小便的时候。我通常正处于嗑药嗨翻的状态。我通常正处在那个状态。所以通常我是吃了迷幻蘑菇之类的东西，需要坐下来。
I need my full attention to not be peeing on myself. I see. Yes. Wow. This is in the past. In the past. In the past. Got it.
我需要全神贯注才不会尿到自己身上。原来如此。是的。哇。这是过去的事了。过去的事了。过去的事了。明白了。
Now, this is kind of random, but my grandfather, they added on a little like side room to their house for like a little home office and they put a bathroom in it. And he wanted a urinal. So they had a toilet and they had a urinal. And he was so excited about it. And we as kids were just fascinated by it. I was like, what is that thing? like the girls anyway. And then my dad, when my mom and dad built their house out on our farm,
这个有点随机，不过我外公他们家在房子旁边加盖了一个小房间当作小家庭办公室，并在里面装了一个洗手间。他想要一个小便池。所以他们既有马桶，又有小便池。他对此兴奋不已。而我们作为小孩子觉得非常着迷。当时我想，那是什么东西？不管怎样，就像女孩子用的那样。后来我爸爸在我们的农场盖房子时，
my dad was like, I want a urinal. So there is a urinal in my mom and dad's bathroom. I mean, that's incredible. Yeah. I feel that. That feels like how I needed my bidet. I'm like mesmerized by that story and like in all of it, like in a positive way. I don't want to get us too far off topic, but what kind of bidet do you have?
我爸爸说，我也想要个小便池。所以在我爸妈的浴室里就有一个小便池。我的天，这太不可思议了。是的。我能理解。这感觉就像我当年多么需要我的智能洁身器（bidet）一样。我被那个故事迷住了，完全被吸引了，是以一种积极的方式。我不想把话题扯得太远，但你装的是哪种智能洁身器？
Or what kind of is it like an aftermarket one? It's a, no, no, it's a porcelain bidet that's built into the floor. Okay. It's a full other thing next to my toilet. That's awesome. In hindsight, I could have easily just done the one that attaches to my toilet, but this was like 15 years ago, and I didn't really know about that one. Sure.
或者说，它是那种后装式的吗？它是，不，不，这是一个内置在地面里的陶瓷智能洁身器。好的。它是我马桶旁边的一个独立装置。那太厉害了。事后看来，我完全可以直接装那种安装在马桶上的，但这大概是 15 年前的事了，我当时并不太了解那种。当然。
Well, you're an early adopter. Yeah, that's a bidet adopter. They had them in our house in Indonesia, but it was my Barbie fountain. I rented a home with a bidet, and I could, got so attached to it. When I bought my house, I was like, I need it. Well, now they have the fancy toilet where the bidet is like part of the toilet. Right.
好吧，你是早期尝鲜者。对，我是智能洁身器的早期使用者。他们在印度尼西亚的房子里也有这东西，但那曾是我的芭比喷泉。我租过一个带智能洁身器的房子，然后我就变得对它爱不释手。当我买下自己的房子时，我就想，我必须装一个。好吧，现在他们有了那种智能洁身器成为马桶一部分的高级马桶。没错。
Toto toilet. Yeah. Yeah. All right, while we're all here, where are we all on squatty potties? Yay. Nay. Oh. Nay.
TOTO 马桶。对。对。好了，既然大家都在这儿，我们对“蹲便辅助凳”（Squatty Potty）怎么看？赞成。反对。哦。反对。
Josh got one. And it's a fad. He gets into fads, guys. He's like, this is how we're supposed to go. Yeah, I remember when they were very popular. Yeah. I didn't notice a difference either. It didn't work for me.
乔希买了一个。但这只是一种风潮。他总是赶时髦，伙计们。他当时说，这才是我们上厕所的正确姿势。对，我还记得它们非常流行的时候。是的。我也没感觉出有什么区别。对我来说没用。
My legs aren't long enough. It put me in an odd position. We can be done talking about all this now. Jonathan, thank you so much for writing. And clearly, we all had a lot to say about that. Thanks for sending in your chit chat. All right, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to break down the paper episode seven titled, I
我的腿不够长。它把我带入了一个奇怪的姿势。我们现在可以结束这个话题了。乔纳森，非常感谢你来信。显然，我们大家对这个话题都有很多话要说。谢谢你发来闲聊问题。好了，我们为什么不休息一下？然后等我们回来，我们将解析第 7 集纸业公司，剧名叫做《我爱你》。
Love You. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still figuring it out. No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。有时候你会觉得好像所有其他人都把生活安排得井井有条。他们的爱情生活，无论是已婚、约会还是单身，看起来都游刃有余。但事实是，我认为我们大家其实都还在摸索中。无论你处于浪漫旅程的哪个阶段，心理咨询其实都是个不错的选择，因为你可以找个人倾诉、征求建议，帮你理清自己想要什么，并卸下一些心理负担。
and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, Well, BetterHelp therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time.
是的，或许还能帮你解开过去可能一直拖累你的一些心结。BetterHelp 的心理咨询师都遵循严格的道德规范。他们在美国拥有完全的执照。并且 BetterHelp 会为你提供咨询师匹配承诺。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，说明你的偏好，他们就会为你匹配合适的人。但你猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢，你可以随时更换不同的咨询师。
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com. com slash office ladies. That's better help.com slash office ladies. Well, welcome back to I Love You. Season 1, episode 7, written by Alex Edelman and directed by Jennifer Salada. I'm going to give you a summary.
拥有超过 3 万名咨询师，BetterHelp 是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供过服务。注册并在 BetterHelp.com slash office ladies 获取九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com slash office ladies。欢迎回到《我爱你》。第一季第七集，由亚历克斯·埃德尔曼编剧，詹妮弗·萨拉达执导。我来给大家做个总结。
Okay. Marv is temporarily relocated to the newsroom. You remember Marv. He's like the head honcho, the big boss. The older gentleman. Yes. Yes. So his move down to the newsroom.
好的。马尔夫被临时调到了新闻编辑室。你们还记得马尔夫。他就像是核心人物，大老板。那位年长的绅士。对的。是的。所以他搬到新闻编辑室。
while his office is being painted or whatever, forces the staff to confront their issue with authority figures, and it brings up daddy issues for net. Boy, does it. Meanwhile, as Marelda and Ken team up to solve a mutual problem. I'll leave it at that. Well, we reached out to director Jennifer Salada, and she sent us in some great tidbits.
当他的办公室在粉刷或者干别的的时候，这迫使员工们去面对他们对权威人物的问题，并勾起了内德的恋父情结。天哪，确实如此。与此同时，玛丽尔达和肯组队去解决一个共同的问题。我就剧透到这里。好吧，我们联系了导演詹妮弗·萨拉达，她给我们发来了一些很棒的幕后花絮。
We're going to share them throughout. You guys all know that have been listening. Jen is part of our office family for many years, and it was so great to hear her. voice. Yes. We're going to start with what I'm calling a faky conference room meeting. So Marvin, his team, they're there. They're in the big bullpen and they're watching. And Ned is in the conference room with his crew. And he's like, okay, he's watching us. He's watching us. Like jump up and down, high five, clap. Oh my gosh, point. Yes. Woohoo. And they're just acting
我们会在节目中与大家分享。听过节目的大家肯定都知道，珍妮多年来一直是我们办公室大家庭的一员，听到她的声音真是太棒了。是的。我们要从我称之为“虚假会议室会议”的场景开始。马尔夫和他的团队在那儿。他们在开阔的办公区里看着。而内德和他的手下在会议室里。他说，好吧，他在看着我们。他在看着我们。就像跳起来、击掌、鼓掌。哦天哪，指着。太棒了。耶。他们只是在装模作样地
like they're having this really great, awesome brainstorming meeting for ideas for the paper. And Nicole says, why don't we just have a real. meeting. Adam thinks it's the most fun meeting they've ever had. Yeah. But it worked. Marv is watching them from across the room and goes, wow, impressive. You know what this reminded me of. What? The scene from boys and girls when Jan and all the ladies are in the conference room and Michael literally gathers all the men in the bullpen and he's like, okay, now everybody clap, everybody clap. Oh, laughing, laughing. The difference is that Jan was not buying it at all. No. Marv was convinced, Jan, not so much.
好像在开一场非常棒、非常精彩的头脑风暴会议，为纸业公司寻找创意。妮可说，为什么我们不直接开个真正的会议呢。亚当觉得这是他们开过的最有趣的会议。是的。但这一招奏效了。马尔夫隔着房间看着他们说，哇，令人印象深刻。你知道这让我想起了什么吗。什么？《男孩与女孩》里简和所有女士都在会议室里，而迈克尔 literalmente 把所有男职员都聚在办公区，然后他说，好了，现在大家鼓掌，大家鼓掌。哦，笑，笑。不同之处在于简根本不买账。没有。马尔夫被说服了，简则不然。
Not so much. Well, now Ned is going to leave the conference room. He's going to welcome Marv. He's like, oh, I didn't even know you were there. Ha, ha. Yeah. And he kind sucks up to him a little bit. He does. And I want to shout out Alan Havy, who plays Marv. He's
不太买账。好吧，现在内德要离开会议室了。他要去迎接马尔夫。他说，哦，我甚至不知道你在那儿。哈，哈。是的。他有点拍马屁的嫌疑。确实有。我要向饰演马尔夫的艾伦·海维（Alan Havill）致敬。他
excellent in this episode. Jen actually sent us in an audio clip about working with him, so I think we should hear it. I directed episode 107 of the paper, and I got to work with Alan Havy, who played Marv, who was Ned's boss, and he was brilliant, and I loved working with him. And I thought that I just recognized him from TV, maybe from
在这集里表现极其出色。珍妮实际上给我们发来了一段关于与他合作的音频剪辑，我想我们应该听听看。我执导了《纸业公司》第 107 集，我有幸与饰演马尔夫的艾伦·海维合作，他是内德的老板，他表现得太棒了，我非常喜欢和他合作。我一开始以为我只是在电视上认出了他，可能是从
Mad Men or from movies that he's done. And it wasn't until much later, like, embarrassingly later, that I realized, oh, my God, I directed him on The Office on the episode called Promos, ninth season of The Office. He played Esther's dad, and he was trying to, like, swindle Dwight in some tractor deal. and he was also fantastic in that. Two very different roles, but I did not realize that I had worked with him before. And he was just such a delight in the character of Marv
《广告狂人》或者他演过的电影里。直到很久以后，非常尴尬地很久以后，我才意识到，哦，天哪，我曾在《办公室》里执导过他，那是第九季一集叫《宣传片》的剧集。他饰演埃斯特的父亲，他当时试图在某种拖拉机交易中欺骗德怀特，
and dealing with Ned and his daddy issues. You know, it's so funny, Angela, the first time I saw him on the paper, I had forgotten that he played Esther's dad as well. I just remembered him from Mad Men. But he's so different. He's so different. And we both had that moment of like, oh, crap.
而且他在那集里也表现得非常棒。两个非常不同的角色，但我之前竟然没有意识到我以前和他合作过。他在塑造马尔夫这个角色以及应对内德和他的恋父情结时，真的是一个巨大的惊喜。你知道这很有趣，安吉拉，我第一次在《纸业公司》里看到他时，我完全忘了他也演过埃斯特的父亲。我只记得他在《广告狂人》里的演出。但他太不一样了。他完全不同。我们俩当时都有那种感觉，天哪。
That was, oh, my God. But, you know, in that episode, he has like a baseball hat on. He's a little unshaven. He totally transformed. Yes. But what a great actor. Listen, we're going to get to it about Ned's daddy issues, but there is something about Alan and the way he portrays Marv that I'm like, it's like my dad.
那是，哦，天哪。但是，你知道，在那一集里他戴着棒球帽。胡子也没刮干净。他完全变了个样。是的。但多棒的演员啊。听着，我们等会儿会聊到内德的恋父情结，但艾伦塑造马尔夫的方式有一种特质，让我觉得，就像我爸爸一样。
I'd like to spend an afternoon with him. He does. I mean, he's perfect casting. Mm-hmm. In this scene, Ned is basically just kissing up to Marv. Ken is annoyed by it, but then Ken joins in on kissing. up to Marv. Yes. Then the next scene, Ned is in his office and he's watching Mayor through the blinds. He's given her a card. It's an apology card. It's a photo of a Basset Hound. The card was
我很乐意跟他共度一个下午。他确实如此。我的意思是，他选角太完美了。嗯哼。在这个场景中，内德基本上就是在拍马屁。肯对此感到恼火，但随后肯也加入了拍马屁的行列。是的。然后下一个场景，内德在他的办公室里，通过百叶窗看着梅尔。他给她递了一张卡片。那是一张道歉卡。上面印着一只巴吉度猎犬的照片。这张卡片
originally supposed to say, sorry I missed your birthday, but Ned crosses out some letters and writes some stuff in. So now it says, sorry, I miss identified your sexuality. And Mayor throws it in the trash. Well, Jen had a little story to share about choosing this particular card. Let's listen to it. One tiny little behind-the-scenes moment that I just remembered today was that when Ned gave Mare a card that said, I'm sorry, I misidentified your sexuality. I remember being presented from our awesome props department a bunch of Basset Hound cards and Basset Hound images to put on the card and trying to figure out which sad basset hound looked most like sad donal or sad ned and that was just delightful in one of those what are our jobs moment this is amazing what'd you do today
原本应该是写着“抱歉我错过了你的生日”，但内德划掉了一些字母并写上了一些内容。所以现在它变成了“抱歉，我弄错了你的性取向”。而梅尔把它扔进了垃圾桶。好吧，珍妮有一个关于选择这张特定卡片的小故事要分享。我们来听听。一个小小的幕后花絮，我今天刚想起来，那就是当内德给梅尔一张卡片，上面写着“对不起，我误判了你的性取向”时，我记得我们出色的道具部门呈给我一堆巴吉度猎犬的卡片和图片放在卡片上，然后我们要琢磨哪只悲伤的巴吉度猎犬看起来最像悲伤的唐纳德或悲伤的内德，这真的太有趣了，简直是那种“我们的工作到底是什么”的时刻。这太神奇了，你今天都干了啥？
i had to pick sad basset hound card such attention to detail i know well now mayor has a talking head and she basically says you know what i don't need to be friends with everyone i work with and then she kind of goes after the documentary crew she's like do you guys ever ask questions about journalism? Yeah. I guess they don't. Apparently not. I do have a wardrobe check for you.
我得挑选悲伤的巴吉度猎犬卡片。对细节的关注真是无微不至。我懂。好吧，现在梅尔有一个面对镜头的独白，她基本上是说，你知道吗，我不需要和共事的每个人都成为朋友。然后她有点把矛头指向了纪录片摄制组，她说，你们有没有问过关于新闻业的问题？是的。我想他们没有。显然没有。我得对你的衣着进行一番点评。
What is it? I love Mare's sweater. I did too. Right? Yes. Okay. So I went on this website. It's called warn on TV.net.
什么点评？我很喜欢梅尔的毛衣。我也很喜欢。对吧？是的。所以我上了这个网站。它叫 warn on TV.net。
W-O-R-N, you know, worn on TV. dot net to see if they might have the details. And they did. What? Here you go. It is a cashmere sweater made by Marnie, and they're out of the UK. I want you to guess what? what it retails for.
W-O-R-N，你知道，worn on TV dot net，去看看他们会不会有这件衣服的详细信息。结果还真有。什么？给你看看。这是一件由 Marnie 制作的羊绒毛衣，他们来自英国。我让你猜猜。
$175. $1,569. Mayor can't afford that. I know, and that's USA dollars. So I went to the website because I'm like, that can't be right. And I selected the U.S. version, you know, and that's how much that sweater costs.
猜它零售价多少？175 美元。1,569 美元。梅尔可买不起这个。我知道，而且那是美元。所以我去官网上看了看，因为我想，这不可能吧。然后我选了美国版的网页，你知道的，这件毛衣就是这个价格。
The Marnie Color Block cashmere jumper. Wow. I know. And we're sure that she's not wearing like someone's knockoff version of this cashmere sweater. It's for sure the one. It's really beautiful. It's beautiful.
Marnie 拼色羊绒套头衫。哇。我知道。而且我们确定她穿的不是别人的这件羊绒毛衣的盗版货吗？绝对是正品。真的非常漂亮。很漂亮。
I noticed it. And I mean, I will share in stories because I have the link to it. It is the sweater. I don't think I could wear a thousand dollar cash in your sweater and leave the house. I mean, we all know what I did with my watch that I thought was worth anything. You put it in a safe deposit box. If something's too expensive, I don't understand how people spend thousands of dollars on handbags. Like, how do you ever take it anywhere? That's how I feel about sunglasses. Like,
我注意到了。而且，我的意思是我会在快照里分享，因为我有它的链接。这就是那件毛衣。我觉得我不可能穿着一件上千美元的羊绒毛衣出门。我的意思是，大家都知道我对那块自以为值钱的手表做了什么。你把它放进保险箱了。如果某样东西太贵了，我不理解人们怎么会花几千美元买手提包。比如，你怎么能把它带到任何地方去？我对太阳镜也是这种感觉。比如，
I am going to drop them, shove them in a purse by accident. Here it is. Look, I have a picture of it. The website is called Farfetch. There it is. That's it. That's it. I didn't realize the one sleeve was all burgundy. Yeah. Well, yeah, I couldn't wear it. I buy the knockoff version. probably wouldn't fit as well. That's how they get you. That's how they get you. So next up, Marv is talking to Adam, and Adam says, Marv, look at this old newspaper article. There's this profile of you as a young businessman.
我肯定会把它摔了，或者不小心塞进钱包里。就是这个。看，我有一张照片。这个网站叫 Farfetch。就是它。就是这个。就是它。我之前没发现有一个袖子全是勃艮第红的。是的。好吧，是的，我可穿不起。我会买盗版货的。可能版型没那么好。他们就是用这招吸引你的。他们就是用这招吸引你的。接下来，马尔夫正在和亚当谈话，亚当说，马尔夫，你看这篇旧报纸文章。这里有一篇关于你年轻时作为商人的简介。
And Marv is like, oh, my gosh, where'd all my hair go? And Adam's like, I don't know. That was a real question. And then he says, oh, we also have an obituary ready to go for you. So when you die, it's all set. It's like all I could think about is like how they have the Super Bowl winners baseball hats ready. Oh my God. We talk about that all the time.
马尔夫说，哦，天哪，我的头发都去哪儿了？亚当说，我不知道。这是一个真实的问题。然后他说，哦，我们还为你准备好了一份讣告。等你死了，一切就都准备好了。我当时满脑子想的都是他们是怎么把超级碗冠军棒球帽提前准备好的。哦，天哪。我们老是谈论这个。
Yeah. So they're like ready to go. But they don't know who's winning, but they all immediately have a baseball hat. It's so wasteful because there's like all this merch that then it just gets tossed, trashed. Yeah. I think about that every time I see them put the hats on within three seconds of winning. I know. But anyway, they have his obituary ready to go.
是的，所以它们都是随时准备着的。但他们根本不知道谁会赢，却立刻准备好了一顶棒球帽。这太浪费了，因为所有这些周边商品最后都会被扔掉、丢进垃圾桶。是的。每次看到他们夺冠后三秒钟内就把帽子戴上，我都会想到这一点。我知道。不过不管怎样，他们把他的讣告都准备好了。
I mean, he lets Marv read it. And Marf's a little bummed out by it. He's like, oh, maybe my life hasn't been as meaningful as I'd hoped now that I read it in black and white. I mean, I think it's like two paragraphs. It doesn't seem like they put a lot of effort into it. You know, when I worked at the local television station in college, we had some pre-edited obituary packages. Oh, yeah. Like they've got the video montage ready and the whole thing.
我的意思是，他让马尔夫读了读。马尔夫读完有点沮丧。他说，哦，也许我的人生并没有像我所希望的那样有意义，现在我把它黑底白字地读出来了。我的意思是，我觉得大概就两段吧。看起来他们没花太多心思。你知道，我上大学时在当地电视台工作，我们确实有一些预先编辑好的讣告素材。哦，是的。就像他们已经准备好了视频剪辑和整套东西一样。
Especially if someone is maybe sick or like a very famous person is very old. they kind of have it ready to go. I remember thinking, my gosh, it's just so bleak. Yeah. But this led me on a deep dive. Of what? Did you know that there is a Wikipedia page that is a list of prematurely released obituaries? Of famous people?
特别是如果某人可能生病了或者某个非常出名的名人年纪很大了。他们就会把它准备好。我记得当时想，天哪，这真是太凄凉了。是的。但这引发了我的深入挖掘。什么？你知道有一个维基百科页面，上面列出了提前发布的讣告名单吗？名人的？
Yeah. I mean, the famous people are on the Wikipedia page. I don't know if it's happened to non-famous people. It probably has if they, for some reason, had a pre-written obituary. but did you know that Rowan Atkinson has falsely been reported as dead three times in 2016, 2017, and 2018? What the heck? I don't know.
对。我的意思是，名人都挂在维基百科页面上。我不知道非名人身上有没有发生过这种事。如果有的话，可能是因为某种原因他们写好了预备讣告。但你知道罗温·阿金森（Rowan Atkinson）在 2016 年、2017 年和 2018 年被错误地报道过三次死亡吗？搞什么鬼？我不知道。
He's still alive. Yeah. And he's had to like say, hey, everybody. Guess what? Yeah. I don't know why that's happening to him. Kirk Douglas had a draft of his obituary leaked on People.com in November of 2014. And it still had the headline, do not publish.
他还活着。是的。而且他不得不出来说，嘿，大家好。你猜怎么着？对。我不知道为什么这种事会发生在他身上。柯克·道格拉斯（Kirk Douglas）的一份讣告草稿于 2014 年 11 月在 People.com 上泄露了。上面甚至还有个标题叫“请勿发布”。
And he didn't actually die for another six years. He was 103 when he passed away. Crazy. Yeah. But then this one really got me. P.T. Barnum had a premature obituary published, but it was his request. I guess when he took to his deathbed, he said he would sure love to read what the papers would say about him. So they printed his obituary two weeks before his actual death.
而他实际上又活了六年才去世。他去世时 103 岁。太疯狂了。是的。但接下来的这个真的把我惊到了。P.T.巴纳姆（P.T. Barnum）曾发表过一篇提前发布的讣告，但那是他自己要求的。我猜当他病入膏肓时，他说他非常想看看报纸会对他说些什么。所以他们在他的真实死讯公布前两周把他的讣告给刊登出来了。
Oh, he wanted to be like basically privy to his own funeral. Well, that's the thing. I mean, people have sometimes said like, why can't I be at my funeral? Like, can I hear all the speeches and how much people loved me? It's kind of a shame. I miss it. Yeah. So I guess that was his way of getting that.
哦，他是想基本上亲眼见证自己的葬礼。这就是重点。我的意思是，人们有时会说，为什么我不能参加自己的葬礼呢？比如，我能不能听听所有的演讲以及大家有多爱我？这其实挺遗憾的。我错过了。所以我想那是他实现这一愿望的方式。
But Marv was not interested in reading his premature obituary. It bummed him out. It really did. Now we have a little sort of runner of people reacting to Marv being in the bullpen. Like Detrick freezes around him. Adelola says, oh, I don't like suck up to people, but then she's like super overly chipper and smiley. And then we're going to have a scene between Esmeralda and Ned. She's got a stack of stories that Marv approved, but Ned's like, wait, I had sort of scrapped some of those.
但马尔夫对阅读他那份提前准备的讣告不感兴趣。这让他很沮丧。真的如此。现在我们有一个小小的插曲，大家对马尔夫出现在办公区做出各种反应。比如迪特里克在他周围吓得僵住了。阿德洛拉说，哦，我才不喜欢拍别人马屁呢，但随后她变得超级过度兴奋和满脸堆笑。然后我们将看到埃斯梅拉达和内德之间的场景。她有一叠马尔夫批准的故事，但内德却说，等等，我其实已经毙掉其中一些了。
I have a question. Yeah. Why is Ned killing any stories? Do they have so much content that he can just kill stories? I feel like we're in a beggars, can't be chooser situation here. We 100% are. This whole episode starts with a completely empty dry erase board with the word story ideas and nothing under it. And I'm like, how are they putting out a newspaper every day?
我有问题。怎么了？为什么内德要毙掉任何故事？他们的内容难道多到可以随随便便毙掉故事吗？我觉得我们目前处于“乞丐没资格挑肥拣瘦”的境地。我们百分之百处于这种境地。这一集的开头，整个白板上空空如也，只有“故事创意”几个字，下面什么都没有。我在想，他们每天到底是怎么出一份报纸的？
Like, I feel like they would be lucky to have a single weekend paper, not a Sunday paper, too thick. A Saturday, once a week paper. Here's what's happening around town. Well, here's the thing. Ned is going to go approach Marv about it. And Marv is talking to Kimberly. And as Ned approaches, he's like, hey, buddy, how you doing? You know, Kimberly here, she just sold her one millionth roll of softies. I noticed she was wearing the sweatshirt with the gray sheep that you pointed out, the Softys logo. Well, Ned is not impressed that she has sold one million rolls. But I was. And it got me going to the internet, lady.
比如，我觉得他们能出一份周报就已经谢天谢地了，还不是那种厚厚的周日版。而是一周一次的周六版。这就是镇上正在发生的事情。好吧，情况是这样的。内德去找马尔夫谈这事。而马尔夫正在和金伯利说话。当内德走近时，他说，嘿，老兄，最近怎么样？你知道，这里的金伯利，她刚刚卖出了她的第一百万卷“软软（Softies）”卫生纸。我注意到她穿着你指出的印有灰绵羊图案的卫衣，也就是 Softies 的标志。好吧，内德对她卖出了一百万卷卫生纸并不感到印象深刻。但我很印象深刻。这让我上了互联网，女士。
What did the internet say? Are you going to tell me like how far one million rolls of toilet paper stretches? No, I'm sorry. Is it to the moon? No, I'm sorry. I don't know that. But I did Google real toilet paper salesman. Just that. Okay. Real life toilet paper salesman. And it brought me to one of those AMAs. Yeah. You know, online. And I was fascinated by it. What did you learn? I mean so much. But I'm going to read you just a few things. So, this fella started off the AMA with this. I am a toilet paper salesman. I manufacture sell and distribute private label, bath tissue, paper, towels, napkins, and facial tissue. People peppered him with all kinds of questions. Also, they did a lot of poop bits.
互联网怎么说？你该不会要告诉我一百万卷卫生纸连起来能延伸到多远吧？不，抱歉。是到月球吗？不，抱歉。我不知道这个。但我确实在谷歌上搜索了真正的卫生纸推销员。就搜这个。好的。现实生活中的卫生纸推销员。它把我带到了其中一个 AMA（问答互动）板块。是的。你知道的，网上的那种。我对此着迷了。你学到了什么？我的意思是，太多了。但我只读给你们听几点。所以，这位老兄是以这样一段话开启 AMA 的：我是一名卫生纸推销员。我制造、销售和分销自有品牌的浴厕用纸、纸巾、餐巾纸和面巾纸。大家抛出了各种各样的问题。此外，他们还开了好多关于便便的玩笑。
This guy had to, like, put up with some poop bits. But here's one for you. One person said, do you get a lifetime supply of bath tissue, paper, towels, napkins, and facial tissue? Well, I would think so. He said, I actually haven't paid for toilet paper and paper towels in four years. And I live in a house with three other roommates, and we go through quite a bit. Wow.
这家伙不得不忍受一些关于便便的玩笑。但这里有一个问题是给你的。有人问，你能获得终身免费的浴厕用纸、纸巾、餐巾纸和面巾纸供应吗？好吧，我想应该是吧。他说，我其实已经四年没花钱买过卫生纸和纸巾了。我和另外三个室友住在一起，我们消耗量相当大。哇。
So there's that. Also, someone said, what ply do you mostly sell and what is your preferred ply of toilet paper? He says that they mostly make two ply. He prefers it as well. The one ply is for the people who only use one sheet count as the determining factor during the purchase. One ply is typically a thousand sheet roll and fills like sandpaper. Two ply is absorbent and soft. And frankly, most two ply rolls are made as matches to brand names.
所以是这样的。另外，有人问，你主要卖几层纸的？你首选几层的卫生纸？他说他们主要生产双层纸。这也是他的首选。单层纸是给那些在购买时只把张数作为决定因素的人准备的。单层纸通常是一千张一卷，摸起来像砂纸一样。双层纸吸水且柔软。坦白说，大多数双层纸都是为了匹配知名品牌而制造的。
For instance, there are roles that his company makes for the family dollar store that are comparable to AngelSoft, which is the number one seller in the U.S. But theirs cost $2 less. Huh. Huh. Right? Also, you might be curious what sort of target demographics they really reach out. to when they're doing their marketing. And this fellow said, we target women, mostly ages 20 to 45. So you and I are out. Oh, we're out. They tend to do the shopping. And after 45, Freddie, this is us, Jenna.
例如，他所在公司为“美元家族（Family Dollar）”商店制造的卷纸，可以媲美美国销量第一的 AngelSoft。但他们的产品便宜 2 美元。哈。哈。对吧？另外，你可能很好奇他们在做市场营销时真正接触的目标人群是哪些。这位老兄说，我们的目标受众是女性，年龄主要在 20 到 45 岁之间。所以你和我都不在内。哦，我们出局了。她们往往负责购物。而 45 岁以后，弗雷迪，这就是我们了，珍娜。
What? They tend to be stuck in their ways. Oh. So you're not kidding them to buy something new. Anyway, it was very interesting. And then they talked about how two ply uses a little bit of glue, you know, to like make it to apply and the process and how much money they make and whether something's embossed or have graphics, what graphics they choose and why. It was very interesting. I'm really attached to my toilet paper. You're exactly what he said. During the pandemic when toilet paper wasn't really widely available. Oh, yeah. And they didn't have my toilet paper for months, for months. When I finally got my toilet paper back, I took a photo. myself hugging it. You sent it to me. I know. It's on my camera roll. Wait, what is your T.P. of choice? Cottonel. Contnell. I don't want Charmin. I don't want Angel Soft. I don't want any of your other toilet paper. We clearly aren't sponsored by a toilet paper company. Wait, what about it? I like the little grooves in it. The ridges. Yeah, but I just,
什么？她们往往因循守旧。哦。所以你很难说服她们买新东西。总之，这非常有趣。然后他们讨论了双层纸如何使用一点胶水来制成双层、制作工艺、他们赚多少钱，以及是否压花或带有图案，他们选择什么图案以及为什么选择它们。这真的很有趣。我对我的卫生纸有着深厚的感情。你简直就是他口中的那种人。大流行期间，卫生纸并不是到处都能买到。哦，是的。而且他们好几个月都没有我用的那款卫生纸，好几个月。当我终于买回我的卫生纸时，我拍了一张自己抱着它的照片。你发给我了。我知道。它还在我的相机相册里。等等，你首选的卫生纸是什么牌子的？Cottonelle（高洁丝）。Cottonelle。我不要 Charmin。我不要 Angel Soft。我不要任何其他卫生纸。我们显然没有得到卫生纸公司的赞助。等等，那款有什么特别的？我喜欢上面小小的压纹。那些波纹。是的，但是，它恰到好处地柔软。真的刚刚好。我真的很喜欢。如果我去某地住 Airbnb，有时甚至在任何城市的酒店里，如果我要呆得够久，我可能会去买一包四卷装的 Cottonelle。因为我就是，我不要任何其他卫生纸。这家伙绝对卖不出去他的卫生纸给我。他懂的。他甚至都不会去争取你。
it's exactly soft enough. It's exactly right. I really like it. If I go stay, like, like, like an Airbnb and sometimes even a hotel in any city, I might, if I'm going to be there long enough, go buy a four-pack of Cotonel. Because I just, I don't want any other toilet paper. This guy's never selling me his toilet paper. He knows that. He's not even going after you.
我才懒得理呢。你知道，在大流行期间，雷恩曾说，我有搞到卫生纸的路子。我跟你说过这事吗？没有。哦，天哪。他给你发短信了？他给我发短信了。
I'm going to bother. You know, during the pandemic, rain was like, I've got a lead on toilet paper. Did I ever tell you this? No. Oh, my God. He texted you? He texted me.
如果你需要的话，我有卫生纸的货源。我只是觉得好笑，这种消息居然是从雷恩那儿收到的。他说，有一种竹浆卫生纸。你现在就能买到一整箱。当时我想，你在逗我吧。这太棒了。我们要有卫生纸了。所以我订购了。
If you need it, I've got a lead on toilet paper. It's just funny to me that I got that from rain. And he was like, there's this bamboo toilet paper. And you can get a whole box of it right now. And I was like, you're kidding me. This is amazing. We're going to get toilet paper. And so I ordered it.
我从来没有这么讨厌过一款卫生纸。我讨厌死它了。太粗糙了吗？我不要。当时我想，谁会喜欢这玩意儿？我气冲冲地回信给他。我说，雷恩，你喜欢这东西？
I have never hated a toilet paper more. I hated it so much. Too grainy? I don't eat. I was like, who likes this? I wrote him back, angry. I was like rain. You like this?
你喜欢。喜欢这种卫生纸。比如，当着我的面说。比如你很爱用这款卫生纸。他说，我超爱。我喜欢它的触感，我对它没有任何怨言。我说，好吧，我无法理解你。这在我们的友谊中造成了巨大的裂痕，就因为这款卫生纸。你知道我在说什么吗？他也有点嬉皮士风格。我想是的。好吧，总之，我不想浪费。所以我没有把它扔掉。而且每隔一段时间，每隔一段时间，就会有一卷混进来。摆在我们洗衣房架子的最上面。我甚至不知道它怎么拿下来的。
You like. like this toilet paper. Like, say it to me, like, with a straight face. Like, you're loving this toilet paper. He's like, I love it. I love how it feels like I have no complaints about it. I'm like, well, I don't understand you. Like, it's a big rift in our friendship, this toilet paper. You know what I'm saying? He's also a little crunchy. I guess so. Well, anyway, so I didn't want to be wasteful. So I didn't throw it away. And every once in a while, every once in a while, like a roll makes it in. High up on our shelf and our laundry room. I don't know how it even gets down.
总会看到它，这让我气炸了。我太生气了。顺便说一句，一百万卷卫生纸连起来的长度大约能达到去月球路程的 8%。谢谢你，萨姆。好了，我们可以继续了。女士，我觉得那段太迷人了。我真的这么觉得。我把整个 AMA 都看完了。
They'll be, and it enrages me. I'm so angry. By the way, a million rules of toilet paper will get you about 8% of the way to the moon. Thank you, Sam. All right, well, we can move on. I found that fascinating lady. I really did, too. I read the whole AMA.
乔希刚刚给我发了短信。我们用的是 Cottonelle 卫生纸。Cornell（康奈尔）？那肯定不对。Cornell？从，从，哦，他改了。Cottonelle。你们用的是 Cottonelle。
Josh just texted me. We used Cornell toilet paper. Cornell? That can't be right. Cornell? From the, from the, oh, he edited it. Cottonel. You use cottonell.
哦，是的。我甚至都不知道。好吧，你知道吗？我可以去你家上厕所。你知道吗？你从来没抱怨过我家的卫生纸，现在我终于知道为什么了。我甚至都不知道我们用的是什么。为什么我觉得乔希也只爱 Cottonelle 呢？
Oh, yes. I didn't even know. Well, you know what? I can come to your house and go to the bathroom. You know what? You've never complained about the toilet paper at my house, and now I know why. I didn't even know what we used. Why do I feel like Josh only loves cottonell as well?
我觉得 Cottonelle 的忠实拥趸都是……不，他非常挑剔。事实上，我记起有一次他出差在外，我买了一大堆卫生纸，他回来问，这是什么？他是 Cottonelle 的铁粉。他刚刚给我发了一条链接。他说，安吉，Cottonelle 卫生纸具有独特的清洁波纹质感，每次擦拭都能带走更多污垢，让你感觉干净清爽。
I feel like the cottonell people are... No, he's very specific. In fact, I am remembering one time he was out of town and I bought a bunch of toilet paper and he was like, what is this? He's a Cotonel person. He just sent me a link. He said, Ange, the Cotonel toilet paper features a unique cleaning ripple texture that removes more with each wipe, believing you feeling clean and refreshed.
这是一款很受欢迎的产品。我早就知道了。我早就知道了。是的，我确实知道。不管怎样，内德现在和马尔夫在一起，他对马尔夫说，你知道，你在这里有点打扰到大家了。马尔夫说，我完全理解。如果我越界了，我很抱歉。你不需要爷爷来发糖果。戴着华丽领带的大老板老爹。我懂的。然后他开始离开办公室并说，表现好点，孩子。
It's a popular product. I knew it. I knew it. Yes, I do. Anyway, Ned is now with Marv, and he's saying to him, you know, having you here is kind of disrupting things. And Marv is like, I totally. understand. I'm sorry if I overstepped. You don't need grandpa giving out sweets. Big boss daddy with the fancy tie. I get it. And then he starts to leave his office and he's like, be good, kiddo.
爱你。是的。他说，爱你。他正打着电话。他有点心不在焉。内德有点跟着马尔夫走到办公区，然后他说，我爱你。哦，是的。那种感觉像潮水般涌上心头，天哪，他太需要来自某个人的这种肯定了。办公区里气氛非常尴尬。超级尴尬。而这一切，非常复杂，因为我们还有肯和埃斯梅拉达。他们在一旁冷眼旁观，像是在远处审视着这一切。是的。
Love you. Yeah. He says, love you. He's like on his phone. He's kind of distracted. And Ned kind of follows Marv out to the bullpen and he says, I love you. Oh yeah. It washed over him like, man, he needed that sort of affirmation from someone. It's very awkward in the bullpen. It's super awkward. And this whole thing, it's very complicated because also we've got Ken and Esmeralda. They're sort of watching all of this happen, judgey watching from a distance. Yes.
所以这里发生了很多事。于是珍妮发来了一段音频，谈到她是如何计划拍摄这个涉及多个地点的极其复杂的镜头的。而且它有一个非常惊喜的结局。我很喜欢。我记得当时要想出如何调度那场戏的走位有多么困难，也就是内德把马尔夫拉进会议室的那场戏。然后肯、埃斯梅拉达和妮可在外面偷听，阿德洛拉和特拉维斯也在外面偷听，试图弄清楚该把摄像机放在哪里，才能让他们互相看不见，同时又能让摄像机运动感觉真实且流畅。
And so there's a lot happening here. So Jen sent in an audio clip where she talked about planning this very complicated shoot of all these multiple locations. And it has a very surprise ending. I liked it. I remember how difficult it was for me to figure out how to block the scene where Ned pulled Marv into the conference room. And then Ken and Esmeralda and Nicole were listening outside and Adelola and Travis were also listening outside trying to figure out where to put the cameras so that they wouldn't see each other, but then also have the camera movement feel real and feel fluid
这里有很多事情正在发生。珍发来了一段音频剪辑，她在里面谈到了策划这个非常复杂的拍摄，涉及多个不同的地点。而且它有一个非常令人惊讶的结局。我挺喜欢的。我还记得当初我要弄清楚如何走位那场戏有多难——内德把马尔夫拉进会议室，然后肯、埃斯梅拉达和妮可一直在外面偷听，阿德洛拉和特拉维斯也在外面偷听，要想弄清楚把摄像机放在哪里才不会穿帮，同时还要让摄像机的运动感觉真实且流畅
was really challenging. And I would go down on set all the time when the actors were there and also when the actors weren't there and just try to think of how, you know, when I put the cameras here what I put the cameras here. And one time that I was down there, I think the actors must have not been there. So it was kind of dark on the set. And I was, I'm sprawled out with my diagrams. And I ended up seeing like this sort of shadowy figure walking down across the set and into Esmeralda's office and then coming out. And I looked up and it was Susie, who's the production designer extraordinaire. And I was like, what are you doing here? Like I'm, what am I doing here? What are you doing here? And she was eating lunch and she went to Esmeralda's office because she knew that Esmeralda had some good Italian
真的非常具有挑战性。我总是会去到片场，演员们在那儿的时候我去，演员们不在的时候我也去，然后就试着去想，你知道的，当我把摄像机放在这儿，或者当我把摄像机放在那儿会怎么样。有一次我去的时候，我想演员们肯定不在。所以片场光线有点暗。我呢，就摊开了一堆我的图纸。最后我看到有个像黑影一样的人走过片场，走进了埃斯梅拉达的办公室，然后又出来了。我抬头一看，是苏茜，也就是那位了不起的服装设计师。我当时就问，你在这儿干嘛呢？就像是我在想，我在这儿干嘛呢？你在这儿干嘛呢？她当时在吃午饭，她去埃斯梅拉达的办公室，因为她知道埃斯梅拉达有一些很好的意大利
olive oil because Sabrina's Italian and Susie is Italian. And Susie was like, this is the only good olive oil on this whole lot. So I don't know if that'll be interesting to listeners, but it just delighted me a little behind the scenes tidbit of how things are on set. I love knowing that. Me too. If we ever get to visit again, I want to go try that olive oil. Right? Yeah. It does remind me How I always knew if I wanted a little piece of candy that Phyllis had candy in her desk drawer in the side of the office. Exactly. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we've got more of this Ned I love you business, plus a little around the town. We are back and it's time for office ladies around the town. Sam.
橄榄油，因为萨布丽娜是意大利人，苏茜也是意大利人。苏茜就说：“这整栋楼里就只有这瓶好橄榄油。”所以，我不知道这对于听众来说会不会很有趣，但这确实让我觉得挺开心的，算是一个关于片场情况的小小的幕后花絮。我喜欢了解这些。我也是。如果以后我们还有机会去参观，我想去尝尝那瓶橄榄油。对吧？是的。这确实让我想起，我以前怎么会知道，如果我想吃点糖果的话，菲利斯在办公室侧面的办公桌抽屉里放了糖果。没错。好了，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来后，我们还有更多关于内德“我爱你”的事情，再加上一点“走过小镇”环节。我们回来了，又是时候进行办公室女士的“走过小镇”环节了。萨姆。
Around the town. There it is. I love the fireworks. I do too. Our first bit of news is coming in from Katie G in Idlewild, California. Katie says, I live in a very small town in Southern California called Idlewild. Our town's mayor is a dog. Yes, I'm serious. He is a golden retriever named Mayor Max and is somewhat of a local celebrity. He even has his own calendar. How cute is that? Mayor Max. Mayor Max. Our next around the town comes from Megan W. and West Fargo, North Dakota. Megan says, My 10-year-old son, Bo, earned his first degree black belt in Taekwondo. He worked his way up through the Tiger and Junior programs. The final part of the test is breaking boards.
走过小镇。来了。我喜欢烟花。我也喜欢。我们的第一条消息来自加利福尼亚州艾德尔怀尔德的凯蒂·G。凯蒂说：“我住在南加州一个非常小的小镇，名叫艾德尔怀尔德。我们镇的市长是一只狗。是的，我是认真的。他是一只名叫马克斯市长的金毛寻回犬，在当地算是个小有名气的名人。他甚至还有他自己的日历。这有多可爱啊？马克斯市长。马克斯市长。”我们的下一个“走过小镇”来自北达科他州西法戈的梅根·W。梅根说：“我10岁的儿子博，获得了他的跆拳道黑带初段。他通过老虎和青少年项目一步步努力考出来的。测试的最后一部分是击破木板。
Students have three attempts to break the boards, one with your hand and the other with your foot. He crushed literally and figuratively the boards on his first try. Bo, congratulations! This is fantastic. And finally, Trish M. from Skagway, Arkansas says, on Friday, January 16th, somebody made a Facebook post complaining that somebody else had bought all the eggs from the grocery store. Oh, Jenna, this is like very topical. Oh my gosh. It was heavily implied that it was the local cafe. And there was a call to
学员们有三次尝试击破木板的机会，一次用手，另一次用脚。他在第一次尝试时就字面意义和象征意义上都完美地把木板击碎了。博，恭喜你！这太棒了。最后，来自阿肯色州斯凯圭的崔西·M说：“1月16日星期五，有人在脸书上发帖抱怨说，有另一个人把杂货店里的鸡蛋全买光了。”哦，珍娜，这听天真非常有时代话题性。天哪。帖子里强烈暗示这个人就是当地的一家咖啡馆。而且还有人号召
boycott. Oh, in protest. The owner of the cafe then said he has his eggs still. And, delivered. The whole town was up in arms over the egg lord. So many memes and AI pictures were made. Trish says, I love living in a small town. Trish, Trish, the hubbub. Did you ever figure it out? Who bought all the eggs? It wasn't me, Trish. It wasn't me, I promise. I was just going to ask, Jen, are you sure you're not the egg load of Skagway, Arkansas? Also, if there was ever a mom detective's case, this is it. Oh, my gosh, we've got to go to Skagway, Arkansas and solve this case. I want someone to design us a tricked out van, like a minivan. We wrote a trip to Arkansas. We're going to figure out who ate all these eggs.
抵制。哦，以示抗议。然后咖啡馆老板说他的鸡蛋还在，而且已经送到了。全镇都因为“鸡蛋之王”而群情激愤。大家做了好多的表情包和人工智能图片。崔西说：“我喜欢住在小镇上。”崔西，崔西，这场轩然大波，你们后来弄清楚了吗？是谁把所有的鸡蛋都买光了？不是我，崔西。真不是我，我保证。我正要问呢，珍，你确定你不是阿肯色州斯凯圭的那个“鸡蛋巨头”吗？另外，如果说这世上有什么“妈妈侦探”的案子，那这就是了。天哪，我们得去一趟阿肯色州斯凯圭来破获这个案子。我想要有人为我们设计一辆改装过的面包车，就像迷你厢型车那样。我们开启了一场阿肯色州之旅。我们要找出究竟是谁吃光了这些鸡蛋。
Well, you guys, thank you so much for writing in your around the towns. We're going to continue sharing these as we break down the paper. They're just such a bright spot. I really enjoy them. I do too. All right, let's keep breaking down this episode of the paper. Everyone's going to weigh in on how they feel about Ned telling Marv, I love you. you. Yeah, they kind of just all tease him. Nicole walks up to Detrick and does a spoof of that famous quote, you know, by Julia Roberts' character. You know the one. I'm just going to play it. Okay? Oh, okay. Don't forget. I'm also just a girl standing in front of a boy asking him to love her.
好吧，大家，非常感谢你们写信来分享你们的“走过小镇”故事。在我们剖析《纸业公司》的同时，我们会继续分享这些内容。它们真的是一个大亮点。我真的很喜欢。我也很喜欢。好了，让我们继续剖析《纸业公司》的这一集。每个人都要对内德对马夫说“我爱你”这件事情发表自己的看法。是的，他们基本上都在取笑他。妮可走向迪特里克，模仿了那句著名的台词，你知道的，就是茱莉亚·罗伯茨角色的台词。你知道是哪一句。我这就放给大家听。好吧？哦，好吧。别忘了，我也只是一个站在一个男孩面前请求他爱她的女孩。
So Nicole spoofs that and Detrick's like, you know what, I don't think you should joke about this. And she's like, relax. I was just quoting love actually. And now are you ready for a reason 110 why I don't think Nicole deserves Detrick? Yes. He said, it's from Notting Hill. But whatever. Yeah.
所以妮可模仿了那段台词，而迪特里克却说：“你知道吗，我觉得你不应该拿这个开玩笑。”而她却说：“放松点。我只是在引用《真爱至上》里的台词。”现在，你们准备好听我列出的关于为什么我觉得妮配不上迪特里克的第110个理由了吗？准备好了。他说，那是出自《诺丁山》。不过管他呢。对啊。
He knew it was from Notting Hill. Of course. The reason she's just a girl is because she's explaining just because I'm a famous actress. I'm also just a regular person who has feelings and wants to be loved. Right. Not love actually. Nicole. Actually, Nicole.
他知道那是出自《诺丁山》。当然了。她之所以说自己只是个女孩，是因为她在解释：仅仅因为我是一个著名的女演员。我也只是一个有感情、渴望被爱的普通人。没错。不是《真爱至上》，妮可。其实是《诺丁山》，妮可。
So I know in this episode, Ned is saying, I love you to this father figure who is his boss. Yeah. But it just got me curious in general about just I love you. It's like when do people say I love you in a relationship? Got it. So what is your guess? How long do you think people typically wait after they've started dating to say, I love you? Six months.
所以我知道在这一集里，内德对这个扮演着父亲形象的老板说“我爱你”。是的，但这让我对“我爱你”本身产生了一些好奇。这就好像人们在恋爱关系中究竟是什么时候说“我爱你”的呢？明白了。所以你们猜猜看？大家觉得人们开始约会后通常要等多久才会说“我爱你”？六个月。
Okay, Sam, Matt? Four to five. And Sam, you're with me on six months? Yeah, I'm going to second that. Okay. Well, according to research performed by E-Harmony, the average amount of time in Australia, I guess this was an Australian poll, is two months. Oh.
好吧，萨姆，马特呢？四到五个月。萨姆，你也觉得是六个月吗？对，我附议。好吧。根据e-Harmony进行的一项研究，在澳大利亚——我猜这是一项澳大利亚的民意调查——平均时间是两个月。哦。
And one in ten people say it less than a week into a new romance. Oh, well, they should pump the brakes a little bit. Okay. Well, according to psychology today, there was a study published in 2011 in the Journal of sociological psychology, and they said that the typical amount of time was three to four months. And they broke down who was more likely to say, I love you first, men or women. Can you guys guess? Women. Sam? Women.
而且十分之一的人在一段新恋情开始不到一周内就会说出口。哦，好吧，他们真该稍微踩踩刹车。好吧，根据《今日心理学》杂志的报道，有一项发表在2011年《社会心理学期刊》上的研究显示，典型的时间是三到四个个月。而且他们还分析了谁更倾向于先说“我爱你”，是男人还是女人。你们能猜到吗？女人。萨姆？女人。
Matt? I'm going to say men just to spice things up. Well, I would only say women because I feel like women are more at ease, express. their emotions? Well, Matt is correct. Men? On average, men say I love you six weeks earlier than women. It took men about three months to say I love you and women, it took five. There was also a study conducted across Europe that found that men took, on average,
马特？我猜是男人，这样才够刺激。好吧，我之所以猜女人，是因为我觉得女性在表达情感时更加自如……放松吗？好吧，马特猜对了。男人？平均而言，男人说“我爱你”的时间比女人早六周。男人大约花三个月说“我爱你”，而女人则花了五个月。欧洲还进行过一项研究，发现男性平均需要
107 days to say I love you, whereas women took 122 days. Okay. There you go. Well, I found that very interesting. I did too. Also, people in Australia, you get to it. People in Australia are ready to love you right after two months. So, yeah, it's nice. Go Australia. I know. Well, the sort of ribbing continues. Barry makes fun of Ned. Adelola asked him if his dad and Marv belonged to the same yacht club. And I just want to note for anyone working on the paper, I feel like Ned's show Bible would have a big entry with this episode. Okay. Ned says, okay, my dad doesn't have a yacht. He's a pilot. He owns a Piper Cubs twin engine. He once had a crash land in a field like Harrison Ford. That's definitely show Bible material. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Father flies planes and doesn't say I love you. Yeah. There you go. Continuing with Ned's show Bible, mayor is going to say, look, it's not my job to talk about Ned are the fact that his dad cheated on his mom and forgot his birthday two weeks ago and recently started blood thinners. How does Mayor know?
107天才能说出“我爱你”，而女性则需要122天。好吧。就是这样。嗯，我觉得这非常有趣。我也觉得。还有，澳大利亚的朋友们，你们可真够直接的。澳大利亚的人们在短短两个月后就准备好说爱了。所以，好吧，这挺好的。为澳大利亚加油。我知道。嗯，这种调侃还在继续。巴里取笑内德。阿德洛拉问他，他爸爸和马夫是不是在同一个游艇俱乐部。我只想为所有参与制作《纸业公司》的人说明一下，我觉得内德的剧集设定圣经里在这集会有一个很大的条目。好吧。内德说：“好吧，我爸没有游艇。他是个飞行员。他有一架派珀双发轻型飞机。他曾经像哈里森·福特那样在田野里紧急迫降过。”这绝对是剧集设定圣经里的素材。嗯哼。对啊。父亲开飞机却不说“我爱你”。对啊。就是这样。继续讲内德的剧集设定圣经，市长要说了：“听着，谈论内德可不是我的工作，或者说他爸爸背叛了他妈妈、两周前忘了他的生日、最近还开始服用血液稀释剂，这也不是我的工作。”市长怎么会知道
all of this. I mean, how much are her and Ned talking about real personal stuff? I guess a lot. A lot. Ned is going to address the bullpen and basically be like, stop making fun of me. And then he kind of pokes fun at Barry in an awkward way. He's just getting things way more cringy. And Oscar has a talking head. I loved it. And we haven't heard a ton of Oscar talking heads yet in the series. So I want to play it. Ned seems to be working through something today, which he definitely should be doing, but maybe not at work. Yeah. He's kind of having this emotional spiral.
这一切的。我的意思是，她和内德到底聊了多少这种真正私密的事情？我猜有很多。很多。内德将对全体员工发表讲话，基本上就是想说：“别再取笑我了。”然后他以一种尴尬的方式取笑了一下巴里。他只是把事情弄得越来越让人脚趾抠地了。奥斯卡有一个面对镜头的独白。我太喜欢了。而且我们在剧集里还没听到过太多奥斯卡的独白。所以我很想把它放出来。内德今天似乎在经历一些心理挣扎，他确实应该这样做，但也许不应该在工作时。是的。他有点陷入了这种情绪的螺旋中。
Well, now we're going to cut down to, is this their sort of version of a warehouse, I guess? Mm-hmm. Ken and Esmeralda have sneaked off to talk. I loved this scene, and I pulled a clip of it. I love it so much. I'm so glad you did. It's not my chef's kiss of the week. I've decided to start a new bit lady called Chef's Kiss of the Week,
好吧，现在我们要切换到一个地方，这算是他们版本的仓库吗？我猜是。肯和埃斯梅拉达偷偷溜出去聊天了。我喜欢这场戏，我还截取了其中的一个片段。我太喜欢了。我很高兴你这么做了。这不算是我本周的“主厨推荐之吻”。我决定推出一个新的栏目，女士们，叫做“本周主厨推荐之吻”，
where I highlight my absolute favorite moment from the episode, but this is my chef's kiss number two. Okay. Well, I titled it Plotty McPlotters. I can't wait. Well, I knew Ned was ambitious, but I love you. My God. How will I get him fired now that he seduced the old man?
在这一栏里，我会重点展示本集里我最喜欢的时刻，但这是我的第二个“主厨推荐之吻”。好吧。嗯，我给它起的名字叫“密谋者小剧场”。我等不及了。好吧，我知道内德很有野心，但“我爱你”？天哪。既然他已经把老头子给迷住了，那我以后要怎么才能让他被解雇呢？
Well, there's no way of squeezing between Ned's lips and Marve's ass, is there? We need to get rid of one. The lips? No, the ass, protect him. the lips. We need to remove the ass. We need to get rid of Marv. The ass protects the lips. I love them together. So they're going to come up with a plan. They're going to take Marv out. They see their opportunity to replace him. Yeah. Well, they think they're making all these plotting and schemes in private, but then the camera pulls back and we reveal
好吧，根本没有办法挤进内德的嘴唇和马夫的屁股之间，对吧？我们必须除掉其中一个。嘴唇？不，是屁股，保护他。嘴唇。我们得除掉那个屁股。我们得除掉马夫。屁股保护着嘴唇。我太喜欢他们俩在一起了。所以他们想出了一个计划。他们要除掉马夫。他们看到了取代他的机会。是的。好吧，他们以为自己所有的密谋和算计都是私下进行的，但接着镜头拉远，我们发现
the janitor is napping and has heard the whole thing. Yeah. It's Nate, the building's janitor. And he just chimes in and goes, this sounds risky to me. Now we're going to cut to the little lunchroom. We've seen them eating here before. This is where they get their salads. There's obviously like a little place where you can get sandwiches and salads in the building. And Marv is having lunch with his secretary, Anne. Love her.
那个清洁工正在打盹，而且把整件事都听得一清二楚。是的。是内特，大楼的清洁工。他直接插话道：“这听起来可真够冒险的。”现在我们要切换到那个小餐厅。我们以前见过他们在那里吃饭。这是他们吃沙拉的地方。大楼里显然有个可以买三明治和沙拉的小地方。马夫正和他的秘书安一起吃午饭。我超爱她。
Ned is going to enter and he's going to like kneel down at their table, get real low. And he's going to say, hey, Marv, I'm going to be leading a story. meeting pretty soon. Like, do you want to come watch? Do you want to watch me? Yeah. And then he like dabs his food and says, too much grace, we need you healthy. Lady, this is one, this episode, like, it had been a little hard for me. But when I got to this point, I was like, oh my God, this is cringier to me than Scott's tots. When he says, do you want to come watch me? I. But, I started turning in on myself. And then from this point forward, it just became almost unbearable for me.
内德走了进来，他甚至在他们的桌子旁跪了下来，把身段放得很低。他说道：“嘿，马夫，我待会儿要主持一个选题会。你想来看看吗？你想看我主持吗？”对。然后他拍了拍食物说：“求求你了马夫，我们需要你保持健康。”女士，这是这一集里，一开始对我来说还有点艰难。但当我看到这一段的时候，我心想：“天哪，这对我来说比斯科特的那些小淘气们还要让人脚趾抠地。”当他说“你想来看看我吗？”我。但是，我开始感到浑身不自在。然后从这一刻起，这对我来说几乎变得难以忍受了。
To me, this is truly like Scotts tots level cringe. Well, there's someone who agrees with you, lady, about the cringe factor matching Scott's Tots. It's Elizabeth M from West Lafayette, Indiana. Elizabeth says, quote, I loved watching the paper, but this episode was so hard for me. This felt like a worse Scotts Tots because Dono Gleason plays this poor man, desperate for attention and approval so well. I was wondering if you know how he prepared to play this episode so earnestly with the lesser
对我来说，这真的是达到了斯科特小淘气们那个级别的尴尬。好吧，女士，有人和你有同感，觉得那种尴尬程度可以媲美斯科特的小淘气们。她是来自印第安纳州西拉斐特的伊丽莎白·M。伊丽莎白说：“引述一下：‘我喜欢看《纸业公司》，但这一集对我来说太难熬了。这感觉比斯科特的小淘气们还要糟糕，因为多诺·格里森把这个极度渴望关注和认可的可怜男人演得太棒了。’我一直在想，你知不知道他是如何做准备的，才能把这一集演得如此真挚？如果换作一个较弱的
actor this whole episode could come off gimmicky and insincere, but Gleason really makes you believe everything his character does. I think that's why it's so hard to watch is because he's so believable. He's so earnest. Yes. Like he's playing it so incredibly real that it just, And also, I think he's playing it so honest. I need someone to pull him aside and be like, hey, I'm just checking in on you.
演员，整集都会显得像是噱头十足、不够真诚，但格里森真的让你相信他角色的所有行为。”我想这就是为什么这一集这么难看的原因，因为他演得太真实了。他太真诚了。是的。就好像他演得极其真实，以至于……而且，我觉得他演得太坦诚了。我需要有人把他拉到一边对他说：“嘿，我只是来关心你一下。”
Well, that would be mayor if they weren't on the outs. They weren't fighting. That's the thing. He would not have gotten this far if mayor was engaged with him. Right. Right? Yeah. Well, next up, Esmeralda and Ken have pulled Nate aside.
好吧，如果他们没有闹僵的话，那个人就会是市长了。他们当时在吵架。这就是问题所在。如果市长还跟他保持联系，他也不会落到这步田地。对吧？对吧？是的。好吧，接下来，埃斯梅拉达和肯把内特拉到了一边。
They're like, did you overhear us? He's like, yes. They're like, did you hear the whole person? plan. He's like, I did. And now they've got to win him over. Yes. They need him on their side and not like sharing this with anyone else. So they're like, what if we give you like a great new job? Mm-hmm. And all you have to do is never tell anyone what you heard. They're like, we could make you the head of marketing. Yeah. And I love this part where he says, he's like, you know what? Gosh, I I just want to make sure I could do like a good job at this new job.
他们问：“你刚才都听到了吗？”他说：“听到了。”他们问：“你听到整个计划了吗？”他说：“听到了。”现在他们得把争取他加入。是的。他们需要他站在自己这一边，而不是把这事告诉别人。所以他们说：“如果我们给你一份很棒的新工作怎么样？”嗯哼。你唯一要做的就是永远不要把刚才听到的事告诉任何人。他们说：“我们可以让你当市场部经理。”是的。我特别喜欢他接下来的这部分，他说，你知道吗？天哪，我只是想确保我能在这份新工作上干得不错。
You know, like, he's like, I want that. But like, will I be good at it? They're like, you'll be great. So sweet. Nate is played by comedian Nate Jackson, and he's really good in this. He's super funny in it. Well, now we're in this conference room meeting when Ned is pitching story ideas. And he pitches one about the toll roads.
你知道的，他就好像是，我想要这个。但是，我能干好吗？他们说：你绝对能干好。太可爱了。内特由喜剧演员内特·杰克逊饰演，他在里面的表现真的很棒。他在里面超级搞笑。好吧，现在我们来到了这个会议室开会，内德在推销选题创意。他提出了一个关于收费公路的创意。
And no one likes it. It doesn't sound interesting. And then Marv is going to pipe up and he pitches the idea. of Jeep week. Jeep, like the car, right? Yeah. And everyone is really enthusiastic. And Ned's like, no, no, no, but the toll roads. And everyone's like, we want Jeep week. And then there's this back and forth. And ultimately, Marv is going to excuse himself. And Ned is furious with his team. And he's like, you made me look stupid in front of the boss. Because he's like a little kid. Yeah. Exactly. Well, next up, we're going to have a Nate talking head. He is so excited about his new job as head
结果没人喜欢。听起来一点意思都没有。然后马夫插话了，他提出了一个创意——吉普车周。吉普，就是那种车，对吧？是的。大家都表现得非常热情。内德却说：“不，不，不，但是收费公路……”大家都说：“我们要吉普车周。”然后就是这样一番拉扯。最终，马夫借故离开了，内德对他的团队大发雷霆。他说：“你在老板面前让我看起来像个傻子。”因为他就像个小孩子一样。是的。没错。好吧，接下来，是一个内特的独白。他对自己作为市场部经理的新工作感到兴奋不已。
of marketing. He's explaining some of the research. He's already done. He really feels like Enervate is not taking advantage of their social media. Ken and Esmeralda are coming down the hallway and they see Nate talking to the camera crew and they're like, oh, what? You talk to the camera crew now? And Nate's like, yeah, but it's fine. I mean, the camera crew, they already know about your evil plan. They ask me about it. So now Esmeralding can spiral and they do this ridiculous this joint talking head where they say, you know what? We were just practicing a play because we're writing a play. We were practicing a possible scenario for one of the characters.
他正在解释他已经做过的一些调查研究。他真的觉得“内纳维特”公司没有充分利用他们的社交媒体。肯和埃斯梅拉达走在走廊上，他们看到内特在跟摄像组聊天，于是他们说：“哦，什么？你现在跟摄像组聊天了？”内特说：“对啊，不过没关系。我是说，摄像组他们已经知道你们的邪恶计划了。他们问我关于这事的事。”所以接下来埃斯梅拉达和肯就慌了神，他们做了一个荒谬的双人合体独白，说：“你知道吗？我们其实是在排练一出剧，因为我们在写一出剧。我们在为其中一个角色排练一个可能的情节。”
And yeah, they are backpedaling, back peddling. This is my chef's kiss moment of the episode. We are practicing a play. Well, we're writing a play. Yes. It's the truth. We are writing a play together, our first. Our first.
而且是的，他们在疯狂地打圆场，疯狂地掩饰。这是我本集的“主厨推荐之吻”时刻。我们是在排练一出剧。好吧，我们是在写一出剧。是的。这是真的。我们正在一起写一出剧，这是我们的第一部。我们的第一部。
And we were just trying to work out what one of the characters would do in a certain scenario. Yes. In a certain scenario, these characters would take over, which is a very common plot in so many plays. Well, a mutiny, basically. I mean, it's been done to death, so why not, you know, do that again? Why not? But not. But not. We could do anything else. We could do a movie about a musical, about a movie, about a musical, right? What it was was, it was a loyalty test. Yes.
我们只是在琢磨其中一个角色在某种特定情境下会怎么做。是的。在某种特定情境下，这些角色会发动叛乱，这在很多戏剧里是一个非常常见的剧情。好吧，基本上就是哗变。我是说，这种桥段已经被拍烂了，所以为什么不，你知道的，再拍一次呢？为什么不呢？但是没有。但是没有。我们可以拍点别的。我们可以拍一部关于音乐剧的电影，关于一部电影，关于一部音乐剧，对吧？其实真正的情况是，这是一场忠诚测试。是的。
We were testing Nate's loyalty. It was a loyalty test. Because janitors, more than anyone, they have to be a loyal. Got to be loyal. Because of the staff they find in the trash or in the toilets. I just thought it was amazing. It just kept expanding and expanding in their crazy silliness to cover up this, like, moment. And none of it seemed like lines.
我们在测试内特的忠诚度。这是一场忠诚度测试。因为清洁工比任何人都更需要忠诚。必须忠诚。因为他们在垃圾桶里或者厕所里发现的工作人员的东西。我只是觉得这太棒了。他们的疯狂胡闹不断膨胀、不断延伸，就为了掩盖这样一个瞬间。而且这一切听起来都不像是台词。
Like, none of it seemed like dialogue. It really seemed like two people in like a furious backpedal. I love this parent. Same. I could watch way more Ken and Esmeralda up to hijinks. I have to imagine they absolutely love getting to do scenes together. They have such great chemistry. Well, this next scene is the one I titled, Cringe Much. Ned writes the Jeep story, and he walks up to Marv and hands it to him and he goes, here it is, but I hated it. And Marv is like, well, then fine, just scrap it. He's the editor. so then Nate like dramatically crumbles it up and tries to throw it towards the trash and he misses. And then Marv grabs another piece of paper and crumbles it up and says, here, try it again.
听起来一点都不像剧本对白。真的就像是两个人在疯狂地打圆场。我太喜欢这段了。我也是。我可以看上一整天肯和埃斯梅拉达胡闹。我完全能想象他们有多么喜欢一起拍戏。他们之间的化学反应太棒了。好吧，接下来的这场戏就是我称之为“脚趾抠地了吗”的那场。内德写好了吉普车的报道，他走到马夫面前递给他并说道：“稿子在这儿，但我恨透了。”马夫说：“那好吧，直接把它废了呗。”他是主编。所以接着内特戏剧性地把它揉成一团，试图把它扔向垃圾桶，结果没投中。然后马夫又抓起一张纸，把它揉成一团说：“给，再试一次。”
And then it's so weird. Ned's like, I don't like you. You're mean. I don't love you. It's so awkward. Lady, just hearing you describe it is making me uncomfortable. This was the scene that I was like. I don't even know.
然后这就变得好诡异。内德说：“我讨厌你。你太刻薄了。我不爱你。”这太尴尬了。女士，光是听你描述就让我觉得很不舒服。这就是让我觉得……的那场戏。我甚至不知道该说什么了。
Yeah, and then Marv just apologizes and leaves. And I'm like, I don't know. Like, Ned would be fired, right? Here's what this episode did for me. It really took me on this ride because I was on like one of my favorite comedy rides ever with Esmerald and Ken. And then I was brought into this just like cringe city with Ned and this Jeep and this Marv and the throwing of the trash. But then right after that, they put me. back on the comedy ride with Marv's secretary Anne storming in and shaming Ned.
对啊，然后马夫只是道了个歉就走了。而我在想，我不知道。我是说，内德早就该被解雇了吧？这就是这一集对我产生的影响。它真的带我经历了一场过山车般的体验，因为我一开始正沉浸在我和埃斯梅拉达、肯一起经历的我最喜欢的喜剧桥段之一中。然后我被拉进了内德、吉普车、马夫以及扔纸团构成的“尴尬之城”。但紧接着，他们又把我带回了喜剧的过山车上——马夫的秘书安气势汹汹地冲进来斥责内德。
It was so great. She was like, make it right, Ned. She's like, go up to Marv and make this right. And she said also that obituary didn't do him justice. Yes. Oscar is going to come in and be a bit of a voice of reason. And he's going to tell Ned, I agree with Anne. Yeah. You need to fix things. But then lady, Ned, that the way they're going to fix things is by writing a better obituary. Yeah, and then all I could think of is he gets the whole team in on it. They group write this obituary, and I'm like, you know what? I'm staring out an empty whiteboard. There's no stories going on this paper.
这太棒了。她说：“把它处理好，内德。”她说：“去找马夫，把这件事处理好。”她还说那篇讣告根本没有真正体现出他的价值。是的。奥斯卡走进来，扮演了一个理性的声音。他告诉内德：“我同意安的看法。是的。你需要把事情解决好。”但是女士，内德，他们解决问题的方法居然是写一篇更好的讣告。是的，然后我脑子里唯一的想法就是，他把整个团队都拉进来了。他们集体写了这篇讣告，而我在想：“你知道吗？我正盯着一块空空如也的白板。这份报纸上根本没有任何新闻报道。”
This is my point. This is my point. How do they do it? A daily paper with multiple articles? This one was going to be real thin. Well, while all of that's going on, Ken and Esmeralda are, you know, Operation Cover Our tracks. So they're going to meet with Marv and they're going to tell him that Nate, the janitor, is taking drugs.
这就是我的观点。这就是我的观点。他们是怎么做到的？一份有那么多文章的日报？这一期内容肯定会非常单薄。好吧，就在这一切发生的同时，肯和埃斯梅拉达正在进行“掩盖我们的足迹”行动。所以他们去见马夫，告诉他清洁工内特在吸毒。
Yes. The hard stuff that makes him invent crazy stories of conspiracy. And you see this news wash over Marv and how saddened he is by it and concerned. And I just was reminded just in this moment about a fantastic actor Alan Harvey is. He's so good. He's so good. and Marv is going to go up to Nate. Yeah, we see the scene in the distance where it looks like they're knelt and prayer.
是的。那种会让他编造出疯狂阴谋论的强力毒品。你可以看到这个消息传到马夫耳中时他的神情，他是多么的难过和担忧。而我正是在这一刻想到了艾伦·哈维是一位多么出色的演员。他太棒了。他真的太棒了。然后马夫走向了内特。是的，我们远远地看到那一幕，他们看起来就像是在跪地祈祷。
Yeah. And Nate kind of looks up and winks at them. And then they start to sing, it's kind of an amazing moment. And Jen has a little behind the scenes for you about it. Let's hear it. One moment that was improvised, I'm not sure exactly by who, but there was an improvised moment between Marv and Nate when they were praying. Nate started singing,
是的。内特抬头朝他们眨了眨眼。然后他们开始唱歌，这真是一个惊艳的时刻。珍为此准备了一点幕后花絮给你们听听。我们来听听。有一个即兴发挥的时刻，我不确定具体是谁想出来的，但当马夫和内特在祈祷时，他们之间有一个即兴发挥的时刻。内特开始唱起
swing low sweet chariot. I don't know if that was his idea or if it was Allen's idea, but I'm pretty sure it came from one of the two of them in that moment. They both started singing the song and it was just so brilliant. So that was one of my favorite improvised moments in that episode. I mean, that's so great. Wow. Nate sings with this rich voice and then Marv just instantly comes right in. Yeah. Amazing. You know what? I'm wondering. though. What? I mean, so that was improvised, which means they used it and then they had to pay for it. They had to get the song rights. Exactly. Well, now I think the final nail in the cringe coffin is Ned is going to present Marv with the obituary and he begins to read it. And Marv just stops him and he's like, hey, you know, whatever this is, we don't need to talk about it. We don't need to do this, okay? I'm not going to shut the paper down because of the personal issue that you're having. I'm not your dad. You know. Yeah, he's like, the only reason I would
《低下你那甜美的战车》。我不知道这到底是他的主意还是艾伦的主意，但我很确定这是他们俩当时某个人想出来的。他们俩开始合唱这首歌，简直太精彩了。所以这成了我在那一集里最喜欢的即兴时刻之一。我的意思是，这太棒了。哇。内特用富有磁性的嗓音歌唱，然后马夫立刻就完美地接了进来。是的。太棒了。你知道吗？不过我在想。什么？我是说，既然那是即兴发挥的，这就意味着他们用了这段，然后他们就得为此付钱。他们必须购买这首歌的版权。没错。好吧，我想“尴尬棺材”上的最后一颗钉子就是，内德把讣告呈给马夫，马夫开始读了起来。然后马夫直接打断了他，说道：“嘿，你知道的，不管这上面写的是什么，我们都不用聊这个。我们没必要这么做，好吗？我不会因为你遇到了个人问题就把报纸给关了。我不是你爸。你知道的。”是的，他接着说：“我唯一会
shut this paper down is if it stopped making money. Yeah. And he said, you know what? I just found out that this really sweet man is battling a drug addiction. I'm going to put my energy there. Yeah. And Ned's like, okay, and he leaves the obituary with him. I do want to point out at 20 minutes and three seconds, a Pepsi can on Marv's desk. Really? Oh, presented like Pepsi can. Do you think that was left behind? No, I think it's product placement. You think it's on purpose? Yes.
关掉这家报纸的理由，就是它不再赚钱了。”是的。他说：“你知道吗？我刚刚发现这个非常善良的男人正在跟毒瘾作斗争。我要把我的精力放在那上面。”是的。内德说：“好吧，”然后把讣告留给了他。我确实想指出，在20分03秒的时候，马夫的桌子上出现了一个百事可乐罐。真的吗？哦，镜头里出现了一个百事可乐罐。你觉得那是遗留下来没拿走的吗？不，我觉得那是产品植入。你觉得那是故意的吗？是的。
Come on. It's so like blatantly in the shot. Yeah, but wow. Oh, yeah. Huh. I mean, maybe that's how they paid for a swing-close, we do. Maybe it is. They're like, someone get me a Pepsi.
拜托。这在镜头里太明显了吧。是的，但是哇。哦，对啊。哈。我是说，也许这就是他们支付《低下你那甜美的战车》版权费的方式。也许真是这样。他们当时说：“来个人给我拿罐百事可乐来。”
Well, Marv is going to have this talking head that is, oh, it's so good. He says, listen, true love isn't something you just say. it's based on like a long time together. Kids don't understand that. You don't have to say it to people that you actually love. And then Anne knocks on the window behind him and says like Marv, don't forget to take those vitamin D pills. And Marv turns back to camera.
好吧，马夫有一个面对镜头的独白，哦，太精彩了。他说：“听着，真爱不是你随口说出来的事。它是建立在长久的相处之上的。小孩子们不懂这个。你其实不需要对你真正爱的人说出来。”然后安敲了敲他身后的窗户说：“马夫，别忘了吃那些维生素D药片。”马夫转过身面向镜头。
He kind of smiles and he's like 42 years. Couldn't do it without her. My brother's wife. Oh, we got a fan letter from. Holette F in Reno Nevada, who said, I cannot wait to hear you ladies talk about season one, episode seven of the paper, I love you, particularly the end with Anne and Marv. They are clearly in love with each other, right? And she's married to his brother. I just love their relationship because you can see clearly how much they care for each other. It's sweet and seems to not cross
他微微一笑，说道：“42年了。没有她我可不行。”我兄弟的妻子。哦，我们收到了一封来自内华达州里诺市的科莱特·F的粉丝来信，她写道：“我等不及听你们这些女士聊《纸业公司》第一季第七集‘我爱你’了，尤其是结尾处安和马夫的部分。他们显然是相爱着的，对吧？而且她嫁给了他的兄弟。我太喜欢他们的关系了，因为你能清楚地看到他们有多在乎彼此。这很甜蜜，而且似乎没有越过
the line. Oh, Colette, I agree. I do too. I mean, they, like, bunch together every day. They spend all day together. Yeah. I mean, it doesn't cross the line, but you do wonder, I mean, we learned in this episode that Marv has no children. Has he never been married? Has he held a candle for this woman all these years and didn't ever want to break his brother's heart and it's just content to work side by side with her? That is so old-fashioned romantic. I know. That's like out of one of your movies that you like. The age of innocence. Yes. I love that book. Just to be able to admire her every day is enough. Yeah, just from afar. Mm-hmm. Well, it's now after hours. The documentary crew is still there.
那条界限。”哦，科莱特，我完全同意。我也是。我是说，他们每天都腻在一起，一整天都在一块儿。是的。我是说，这虽然没有越过那条界限，但你确实会纳闷，我的意思是我们在这一集里了解到马夫没有孩子。他从来没结过婚吗？他这么多年来一直对这个女人念念不忘，却从来不想打破他兄弟的心，于是就满足于跟她并肩工作？这真是太老派的浪漫了。我知道。这就好像出自你喜欢的那类电影一样。纯真年代。是的。我太喜欢那本书了。能够每天默默地欣赏她就足够了。是的，就只是远远地看着。嗯哼。好吧，现在已经是下班时间了。纪录片摄制组还在那儿。
Nate is vacuuming the floor. Everyone else is left. And the camera zooms in on a computer screen. And we see these text messages popping up between Ned and Mayor. Mm-hmm. I guess she's turned in a story. He says, thank you. And then she's, says, you know, basically for what it's worth, he said love you first. And then Ned is like, right? Yes, he feels seen. He's like, right? And then they go back and forth. He's like, well, thanks for not piling on. And she's like, oh, I've been saving him up. And then she just does a series of texts kind of making fun of him. Yeah. For having this, like, dad issue with Marv. And that's how it ends. Yeah. Maybe she's forgiving him. Yes. Yeah. And I guess Ned and Marv are going to be
内特正在吸地。其他人都走光了。镜头拉近到一台电脑屏幕上。我们看到内德和市长之间弹出的这些短信。嗯哼。我猜她交上来一篇稿子。他发了句谢谢。然后她发消息说，你知道的，基本上是“不管怎样，是他先说‘我爱你’的。”然后内德就回了个“对吧？”是的，他觉得自己被理解了。他回了句“对吧？”然后他们俩你来我往地聊了起来。他发了句“嗯，谢谢你没落井下石。”她则回道：“哦，我一直在攒着呢。”接着她就连发了一串短信，拿他开涮。是的。嘲笑他跟马夫有这种“恋父情结”。故事就是这样结束的。是的。也许她在原谅他吧。是的。是的。而且我猜内德和马夫以后会
okay. It seems like it. Yeah. Well, there you have it, everybody. That was episode seven of the paper. We've only got three more of these left. Yeah, big, big thank you to Jen Salada for answering our questions. She's always just the absolute best, and I loved hearing her voice. Guess what I found. What? I just looked through my photos, and I found that picture of me that I sent you next to the Cotonel. It's from September 23rd, 2020. That's how long it took me to find. find my favorite toilet paper. Months. Look, there it is.
没事的。看起来是的。好吧，大家，以上就是全部内容了。这就是《纸业公司》的第七集。我们只剩下最后三集了。是的，非常非常感谢珍·萨拉达回答我们的问题。她总是那么无可挑剔，我太喜欢听她的声音了。你们猜我找到了什么？什么？我刚刚翻看我的照片，我找到了那张我发给你的、我和科托内尔纸巾的合影。那是2020年9月23日的。我花了这么长时间才找到我最喜欢的厕纸。你看，就是那个。
And yet you're very happy. You're so happy there. I know. You and Josh and your Continental. I love it so much. We're not even sponsored by them, you guys. Maybe we should be. All right.
然而你看起来非常高兴。你在那儿笑得好开心。我知道。你、乔什还有你们的科托内尔纸巾。我太喜欢了。我们甚至都没有赞助商，伙计们。也许我们应该找一个。好吧。
Well, we'll see you next week. Thanks again to Jen, and we hope you have a good one. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
那我们下周见。再次感谢珍，祝大家过得愉快。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔。
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audience执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特里》。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。